I think there was actually a headline in
The Daily Beast that was and I'm saying
this verbatim what is wrong with Bret
Easton Ellis so I think if you've
written a piece and you've titled it
what is wrong with Fred Easton Ellis
maybe I've done my job I don't know
[Music]
hello and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special we're joined
today by Bret Easton Ellis the author of
among other things American Psycho and
the brand new book white bread thanks so
much for stopping by I really appreciate
it thanks for having me Ben so I have to
start with the most obvious question so
you've yes you've now come out as anti
anti Trump and this has become your
calling card in a political world to
your anti anti trunks to anti anti Trump
oh yes okay my anti anti Trump stance I
didn't want to get involved with it at
all and somehow Trump forces everybody
into this narrative that's about him and
I guess it started happening
really soon after he announced he was
running for president in the summer of
2015 when he came down that escalator in
the Trump Tower and I began to become
interested in how he was being covered I
can't say it was particularly that
interested in Trump of course I'd known
about him since he emerged on the scene
and even wrote about him in American
Psycho where he is Patrick Bateman's
father figure where Patrick Bateman
keeps wanting wanting to meet Trump
wanting to see him wanting to know what
restaurants Trump likes it's throughout
the books about Trump has been
about 40 times in the book and that was
because when I was doing research on the
book and I was hanging out with those
guys on Wall Street they all loved Trump
and it was something that was really
really kind of unsettling they'd all
read the art of the deal he was as
aspirational figure he had you know this
you know beautiful women hanging on to
him he had this lifestyle that they all
wanted to emulate and I thought it was
amusing to put him in American Psycho
but that was really about all that
interested me about Trump sure I watched
The Apprentice which I someone enjoyed
and I followed his marriages and his
children growing up but I really didn't
think that I'd have to engage with him
on the level that we all had to and I
began to see how he was being covered in
the summer of 2015 and into 2016 and
there was this disconnect between who I
thought Trump was and what he was trying
to do and how the media was covering him
and it was disturbing and it was
and it was bothering me enough that I
started to talk about it on my podcast I
also live with someone who was about as
far left as you can go
I I would say borderline communist
millennial and he and his overreaction
to Trump also was troubling to me I just
couldn't understand how Trump could make
people meltdown and freak out in the way
that some of them did and I talked about
this a lot of might especially the
elites especially the elites that I've
written about most of my life in my
fiction having dinner with them and
seeing them you know get really incensed
over the idea of Trump and I'm talking
about
months sometimes a year after the
election and it was um and so yeah I
started talking about how I was I guess
I was anti anti Trump but that doesn't
necessarily mean that I was Pro Trump
and I was never a Trump supporter I
didn't vote for him but there was
something so bothersome so high-pitched
and hysterical about the reaction to him
that it was quite frankly beyond
annoying and that's that's covered in in
white and I and I talk about this a lot
of my podcasts what is it about Trump
that causes such massive TDs the
impression that I get for a lot of these
folks is they consider themselves
sophisticates and here comes along this
kind of boorish fellow from New York who
doesn't play by any of their niceties
and it's like they mask their hatred for
the affectation with a hatred for his
supposed politics so remember I was
sitting at some lunch with with David
Mamet actually and we were in you know
the middle of Santa Monica it's a
beautiful day outside and it's the
middle of the day and yet in Santa
Monica everybody can take lunch off so
everybody's enjoying themselves having
two hundred dollar bottle of wine and
we're talking about Trump and we're
noting to each other that if we said his
name people would pretty much start
screaming aloud and talking about how
the end of the world was nigh in the
middle of this beautiful restaurant in
Santa Monica because they just had to
save America and it's just it is
bewildering living out here and you deal
with these folks a lot more than I do in
Hollywood but this this notion that
they're saving the world by being part
of the resistance where where's this
coming from that's a very good question
and it has to stem from something about
I might really believe the
Trump's aesthetics I'm not even sure if
it's his policies I'm not even sure if
it's even whatever ideology he might or
might not carry with him it really seems
to be aesthetics it seems to be that
this borscht clown you know walked into
the china shop and started knocking
things all over the place with his
orange skin and his weird hair and his
you know this kind of persona that look
I have always said you just cannot take
Trump literally if you take Trump
literally your head is going to explode
you've got to understand the overall
message that Trump is putting out there
because in a lot of ways he is really
transparent he is a transparent person
on one level even if he lies a lot
and you have to be able to juggle that
and understand okay
I get that when he's saying this he's
actually meaning this when he's saying
this he's actually meaning this so if
you're gonna let this aesthetic really
throw you so off-course then you've
really got to I don't know think a big
stiff drink at the bar and and start
realigning how you feel about this
person because it what you're reacting
towards and how strongly you're reacting
about it is this there's a disconnect
also he doesn't he doesn't care I
believe he doesn't care I know
everyone's oh this is really getting to
trump this isn't really gonna upset and
this is really I don't know how much and
I also don't know how much the
resistance really interest him at all I
mean I don't know how much he listens to
to to the resistance but getting back to
what you're talking about I really
believe it all stems from how he looked
and how he acts and maybe was in a
package like Mitt Romney maybe be easier
to take well well this I think is is one
of the the keys to why Trump supporters
there's this huge disconnect so Trump
supporters look at it and they say this
man is as honest as the day is long
he's incredibly honest he speaks for me
whatever he says that comes out of his
mouth at least he's being honest people
on the Left think that he's lying like a
rug all the time and everything that
comes out of his mouth is a lie and
people on the right say okay well Barack
Obama lied to us all the time also and
he didn't even have any problem with
that it's like everyone wants to treat
Trump is something out of the box when
in reality in political terms he kind of
is just a politician right I mean he he
says
stuff that's not true but he says it in
the service of whatever he thinks he
needs to get done today
but the fact that he's so transparent
about it non smooth about it is what I
think is sticking with a lot of folks
you know I agree and I also think that
there is just this there's a stand-up
comedian there that just drives people
crazy as much as it makes people love
him and there's something about that
that it's kind of accessible in a way
the way that Trump behaves and the Trump
presents himself to people he seems like
he or someone trying to be in every man
in a lot of ways even though of course
he probably sees himself much better and
much higher plane than the everyman but
um I think there's something about that
that II mean look if you watch one of
his speeches at one of these rallies it
really is kind of remarkable stand up
and a lot of it is funny that's the
other thing regardless if you hate Trump
where you find him repugnant he's also
funny and he's funny in a way that is
you know even as someone who is not a
trump supporter there's some he says
some funny stuff in a way that I've
never seen a president in my lifetime
and I'm 55 and I've been around for you
know whatever many many decades I've
never seen a president actually behave
this way and again you can either take
it in in the way that it's simply
offered or you can turn it into a
disastrous horrible narrative that's so
full of darkness and it is going to
destroy the country and if not the
country the world and you're gonna be
really unhappy you got to be a really
unhappy person yeah it's funny when I
think about Trump in sort of a cultural
way one of the things that I wonder if
it if this is what drives the left nods
is that he is the right answer to a
bunch of things that the left really
loves so one is cultural dominance that
the left is ascendant in culture they
dominate culture particularly Hollywood
at nearly every level which I'd like to
talk to you about a little bit more in a
second and Trump is the right version of
Hollywood which is to say he was a
d-list celebrity though that was in
favor of them or at least not pissing on
him and they said okay well okay fine
he's our cultural guide left one this
this this boob is your culture I say
well hey you were the one who cast him
in The Apprentice and then made a thing
of him for ten years at the same time he
is sort of the right to answer to Jon
Stewart and to John Oliver of course
people
this merger of politics and comedy who
have decided that sometimes they're
politicians and sometimes they're
comedians and you're never gonna be able
to tell which one and Trump is just that
except all the way and then he's also
the answer to the left suggestion that
they are in touch with the common man
and here's this guy who kind of runs
around in this tie that's from the 1980s
that's all the way down to his knees and
is wider than the river potomac and he
and he you know is is our answer to on
the right you know the common man
problem in the left looks at this and i
think that it's almost like looking at
this bizarro mirror image of themselves
and they don't like what they see
I'll take my well no it's not only that
but you have to understand then in then
in the movie that was playing out in
2015 and 2016 he also beat the Queen he
also beat madam Hillary and that is
another it's not only that he that he
won the election but it was that it was
him who won the election over her and I
think that is the most painful aspect of
it it's not only that Trump to them is a
big boob and he seems like a fool and
they think he's going to destroy America
as we know it it's that he stepped in
place of her and that still must sting
and it still does for a lot of people I
know even people I know didn't
particularly like Hillary Clinton but
it's a bit that's a very tough thing to
swallow I think on the left as well as
the idea that he came in and basically
erased Barack Obama's legacy in a fairly
short amount of time and I remember I
was sitting with someone actually a
close friend of mine from college who
had raised a ton of money for Hillary
Clinton
Belair showbiz Jewish the whole package
here in LA and I've gone to call it with
them very good friends with them and you
know he was somewhat disillusioned by of
course Trump getting elected but about a
year later we were having dinner in a
restaurant Beverly Hills with a couple
of friends of ours and he said you know
I really can't believe it how effective
a president was Obama if Trump of all
people can come in and completely erase
this legacy may be not effective at all
I think that is an incredibly painful
pill for the left us wall in its and it
makes them very angry and it makes them
overreact at things and it's um
it is I think part of the the narrative
that again stings the most so how do you
get away with saying all the stuff I
mean you work in Hollywood you still
work in Halle we know what I would say
that I have always worked I've been an
outsider in Hollywood that I work on the
fringes I work on an independent film
I'm not I've never been hired by the
studio's I've written many many TV
pilots but nothing that has been made I
have made a living in Hollywood but I
really have never seen myself as a
player as someone who is part of the
scene rarely go to parties rarely go to
red-carpet events stop going to
screenings and it's always kind of been
that way I've always I know a lot of
people in Hollywood and I have a lot of
friends because we all kind of grew up
together and I mean I can take a meeting
but it doesn't necessarily mean that I
am working in mainstream Hollywood
actually a lot of people aren't working
necessarily a mainstream all especially
we talk about the movie business because
the movie business is really just about
you know a group of riders trying to
make animated animated films and and
Marvel movies so it's not really as if
there is this huge pool of screenwriters
like there once were writing movies for
adults I mean a lot of the screenwriters
I knew who I came of age with they were
making really good money in the 90s and
into the 2000s now are you know I think
one is overseeing a diner and oh I
another one is selling real estate in
Boise I'm not kidding I mean that is
really where a lot of people went when
everything kind of dried up in terms of
being extremely well paid for your
screenwriting surfaces it really is not
that lucrative anymore and I can
probably do far better in books and
writing books and I then I can in terms
of you know making a living as
screenwriter so I look I'm also not
walking around town
with a manga hot on drooling and saying
a much I love Trump so it is and a lot
of people know me as being a bit of a
contrarian and as someone who you know I
I don't consciously want to do it but I
guess go against the grain and whatever
the collective group think in the moment
is and I think I'm known as that and
I've been known as that for many many
years so I don't know if it's that
shocking that I am anti anti Trump to it
to a degree but you know that's what
this book is about and it's very
interesting to see how the mainstream
media did react to the book because they
reacted exactly as I prophesied in the
book which is they're going to they went
nuts
they went absolutely crazy and I think
there was actually a headline in The
Daily Beast that was and I'm saying this
verbatim what is wrong with Bret Easton
Ellis so I think if you've written a
piece and entitled it what is wrong with
Freddie's Kanellis you maybe I've done
my job I don't know but I don't worry
about I really don't worry about this
notion I mean it was an extremely
liberal Enclave but there are there are
little pockets of conservatives around
there and there it's certainly as I
write about in white not all of LA went
blue there was this little section of
Beverly Hills that went red right above
sunset the north eastern edges of Suns
that so on so I don't know I I also feel
that you that as someone who has a
podcast and as a writer and a cultural
commentator that you have to be true to
yourself and you simply have to and let
the chips fall where they may look I'm
sure I haven't gotten a job because of
what I talked about in white or what
I've been talking about in my podcast
for the last two or three years and I'm
sure one or two things have been have
not moved forward because of that but on
the other hand what do you do do you
just become a pod person and just start
start spouting the groupthink and I
don't know living a sad little life of
desperation but it is true I mean I'm
nope I know a couple guys who were
kicked off of a sports team in 2016 a
look kind of like a celebrity like
writers directors that because they were
they cracked
both Hillary Clinton jokes and locker
room I mean that's how bad it can be
they were not asked back so the town can
can be that way but it just seems um I
don't know if sometimes I think it's
going to calm down go away but I don't
know okay so in a second I want to ask
you about you know then not only how
you've sort of been treated in the peer
group but also some of the things that
you've said that have been seen as
contrarian and get to that in just one
second but first let's say the today's
podcast doesn't go well and I need to
hire somebody while hiring used to be
hard multiple job sites stacks of resume
is a confusing review process today
hiring can be easy you only have to go
to one place to get it done zip
recruiters comm slash been guest because
I have a guest
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who posted on
zip recruiter at a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruit comm slash been
guest that zip recruiters calm slash
been guest be and GU est zip recruiter
comm slash been gas zipper career is the
smartest way to hire which is why my
employees should do a fabulous job today
otherwise we could be looking for a new
employee at zip recruiter okay so when
we talk about the sort of cultural
censorship in Hollywood one of the
things that you did on your podcast you
do in white that I've not seen anyone
else do is you will honestly critique
other artists other people in the movies
you'll actually give your opinions about
things which is unique I mean I speak to
a lot of conservatives who are in
Hollywood and many of them even in
private conversation won't say anything
about movies or about other people who
are working or their skill set
specifically because they're afraid of
the blowback obviously you've done that
and it makes you one of the more
interesting kind of critics of film and
one of the areas where I've seen you do
that repeatedly is on movies about folks
who are gay in Hollywood movies about
race in Hollywood though so what's your
approach to critiquing film because
there's so much politics that's invested
in this very well if you um if you want
that what your
talking about to stifle your real
feelings about a movie that's a problem
in a way I I don't think I'm ever mean I
don't think I'm ever purposely hurtful
for someone who created something or
acted in something I just gave my honest
reaction to what I saw and how I felt
about it and what I think what I'm
thinking about it and wanted what it uh
and how it and how it affected me that's
all I'm doing
and I really stress style and aesthetics
over ideology movies are about style
movies are about an individual filmmaker
I believe and that the best movies are
made with one person's vision and the
best movies are really the message is in
the aesthetics the message is in the
style I am NOT a fan of movies that are
all about ideology that are about
victimhood and unfortunately that has
made it seem like I am a homophobe even
though I'm a gay man that I'm a racist
and then I'm a sexist because I don't
like the the kind of that approach
towards movies about gay people about
black lives and about female empowerment
unless it is fold into genre and then I
really do like those movies but I don't
like your puremessage movies and every
year a lot of those get made or maybe
less so but a lot of them get rewarded
and that's a little annoying you know
that representation becomes more
important than how you make a movie is
something that is has been bothersome to
me and I talk about that a lot on my
podcast when I'm talking about current
movies on this podcast is about to be
released I talked about - I guess you'd
call them female and power but movies
that are directed and created by women
book smart and late night and one fails
because it's all about ideology it's all
about the message of inclusivity
inclusivity and feminism and
intersectionality and the work force and
now if someone comes in and wipes away
all
the middle-aged white men then
everything is going to be so much better
with is you know this is diverse cast
that's now at the writing-table that's
late night and the other movie which is
also written and directed by women and
it has a female empowerment vibe is a
teen comedy I prefer the teen comedy a
lot more than I prefer the message movie
so you know you again you have to be
comfortable with what a path you go on
when you talk about movies but I but I I
appreciate people who are honest I
appreciate people who are honest about
my work
I've lived with people who haven't
responded to my work I've lived with
people I live with someone right now
really hates Americans like oh anomaly
it doesn't like it at all I'm completely
fine with that I know people are
sensitive and I know people get a little
touchy about things but I always I hope
that I come at film with a certain
intelligence and a certain knowledge and
that I know what I'm talking about and
then I'm not just there like saying how
much they suck or how dumb this is but
that it is usually a kind of deep dive
that treats the movie very very
seriously
but you know again if there's blowback
on that that's something you also have
to deal with but I still have a lot of
friends who are filmmakers who whose
movies I have a particular lack of
producers who whose movies I haven't
liked and I'm quite honest with them and
it doesn't seem to hurt our
relationships it seems like particularly
around Oscar season there's always this
attempt to award as you say all these
kinds of films that you say you like and
it's a particularly rotation I think to
a lot of folks including people in
mainstream America which is where I
think there's some crossover here I
think there are a lot of folks who look
at the Oscars every year and they say I
haven't seen any of these films and then
I look at the Oscar previews and
basically I can tell who's gonna win
Best Picture simply by looking at who
checks the most woke boxes if the
moonlight was absolutely gonna win the
Oscar because it was the locust film
that year it was gay and it was black
and it was impoverished and there was no
question that it was going to win the
Oscar and you see that almost every year
I mean they're just certain films where
it checks enough boxes that people can
feel good about themselves in the
Academy never having watched it but then
having signed off on it
on the envelope and it's creating this
massive culture gap between the stuff
that people actually watch and then the
stuff that this group of people
want to be able to brag to their friends
about I mean that's what it feels like
from the outside it feels like maybe
this stuff is meaningful to the creators
on a certain level but on an artistic
level there are not a lot of people out
there in the middle of the country who
are desperate to watch moonlight that is
not a movie that is going to pick up
huge scabs of people in orders gonna do
a whole hell of a lot for gay
empowerment if nobody ever watches the
film well I think the problem with
moonlight and I talk about this in my
book I mean and what and what I'm
shocked to find is that so few people
have really seen moonlight because the
other thing that strange is that um you
know it's not necessarily moonlights
fault in a way that it became embraced a
small little movie I don't think it's
Barry Jenkins fault I don't think he's
pushing any kind of agenda I think he
made the kind of movie that he wanted to
make and I also think that sometimes we
mistake all of this ideology in
moonlight yes he's poor he's gay he's
black it is an orphan you know two
degrees his mother's a drug addict and
we and sometimes we missed the point
that maybe it's really a movie about
loneliness you know maybe it's just that
I know people who really like the movie
respond to it on went on that on that
but I also think that moonlight became
inordinately rewarded at that at those
Oscars I actually thought la-la-land
was going to win Best Picture that year
I think what happened to the narrative
of moonlight is that it opened in such a
fraught period in 2016 where it seemed
like every week we saw black men shot on
camera and the body has just had piled
up and it was just this this inescapable
thing and so when we see these you know
the vibrant bodies and moonlight I think
it touched a chord and a connection was
made in the entertainment press and then
it seeped over into Hollywood that this
wasn't a movie about gay representation
which it really was about being gay and
it became a movie about black
representation about black lives matters
and I think that's what started the ball
rolling for moonlight but it's true it
has to be a certain kind of movie though
or else there's going to be a lot of
complaints and I think moonlight is soft
enough and innocuous enough that no
one's really going to complain that but
no one got
that one for example best picture unlike
this pasture when greenbook won best
picture and the entertainment press had
a meltdown and Hollywood in some way had
a meltdown I mean if you were watching
people's Twitter feed who are mainstream
critics or people involved in Hollywood
involved in Hollywood a little less
because they might have to work with
these people in his producers it was it
was as if that movie which I do think
has its own progressive elements
certainly the way that they deal with
the gayness in that film seems very
progressive in a way where because it's
just kind of shrugged off and and the
main character
Tony vote along or whatever is not not
bothered by dr. Shirley's gayness and I
thought that was a kind of a progressive
step but I don't know it but again it is
that is the kind of movie that is is
rewarded in Hollywood but I have to say
but I thought there was something about
green a green book that was very hopeful
it was out of all the black teen movies
last year whether it was black Klansmen
whether it was hard to bother you
whatever they were they were all
hopeless there was kind of fatalism and
I kind of negativity about them and I
think part of what made people like
green book so much is that it offered a
chance to mend for people to come
together and I cannot believe that
people just didn't want to hear that
message you actually don't want to hear
that message and reward this that was a
very telling moment in the culture
people were pissed I mean people are
really pissed I mean there's there's a
billboard out there on Sunset Boulevard
of Trevor Noah
for the Emmys saying don't green book
this thing he's now using it as a phrase
it's like you you blew it if you give
green book an award because there's this
sort of view that this represents the
baby boomer take on race that it's like
a Joe Biden take on race where we can
all come together in the end and be
friends and in reality we know after
this many years that we cannot be
friends that there is no great coming
together that can happen so we voted for
this you're voting for a fantasy or as
if you voted for black Klansmen and
Spike Lee or if you voted for a straight
could talk which wasn't top but but they
think should have been many of the
then that would have been a better
representation of what race actually is
in the United States well the Academy is
full of baby boomers and a lot of people
are making those movies so it wasn't
necessarily a surprise to me that that
movie movie won that movie won but but
what was surprising was that I know so
many people who liked it I know a lot of
people who liked it maybe secretly and
they were saying I loved I loved a green
book it was like and it made me feel
good it was there was hope at the end
that these two characters so divided
finally saw past their differences and
now together sure a fantasy but at least
there's a hopeful message there and yet
the movie is what it is I mean it's not
a great film it it it's kind of another
Road comedy but I don't know I liked it
a lot and uh and I guess I guess because
it's under the guise of a kind of buddy
comedy and it and it has genre elements
to it maybe that's why I liked it yeah
that's why I like the first half a black
Landsman I think the first half of black
Landsman was a really good spike Lee
movie kind of a throwback to 70s
blacksploitation cop movies and I really
like the feel of it and then it goes all
Spike Lee and then it gets very
ideological and then all the clowns when
I'm watching The Birth of a Nation while
he's giving a speech about a lynching he
saw and it just the movie just
completely goes off the rails and
becomes a complete ideology losing sense
of what I think movies do best with
which is following their style and
following their aesthetics do you think
that there is any sort of way that they
the cultural gap can be bridged at this
point because it feels like the vast
majority of Americans want to watch
Marvel flex I understand this is in the
theater if you're gonna Shaw 20 bucks
you want to see big explosions on screen
and all of that but it seems like there
are only two types of movies that
Hollywood is making woke movies and
giant spectacle movies and nothing in
between it's basically the Poseidon
Adventure or whatever is the locus movie
of the day and there's nothing that just
sort of is a broadly appealing nice
movie unless it's a kids movie like it's
g-rated films more Avengers or something
so woke that if you are a Bible Belt
voter the chances that you
want to see it or at least relatively
low well I don't know I mean the problem
is how well does do these woke movies
really do and are they being made by
Hollywood or are they being made on the
outside of Hollywood by independent
production companies because I don't
think Hollywood is really doing anything
at all except the movies are talking
about and so you have the independent
film scene which is making these movies
and often a lot of the times for
Sundance a lot of these movies are made
to premiere at Sundance and be dropped
into the glow of the festival where you
have writers there or hyping up
everything possible because you know
they're the places they work for they've
got to justify going to Sundance so
they've got up we found four major
amazing movies and you know you're also
a mingling with filmmakers and you're
also getting drunk at parties with all
of these people so there is this there
is an overinflated buzz by about a lot
of the movies that come out of Sundance
that is both a gift and a curse
sometimes it's a gift because in that
heady atmosphere people are now writing
checks for twelve thirteen million
dollars for for two the rights to
release a movie and then it's a curse
because usually these movies come out
and they completely bomb so I don't know
but I do think the festival circuit is
one of the reasons why so many of these
movies are getting made because they get
a lot of attention at the at those
places I don't necessarily think that
audiences are craving it I think
audiences are craving really good movies
and quite honestly I think film critics
are craving really good movies too I
just don't believe the film critic that
says oh my god I just saw the most
amazing thing at South by Southwest it's
this you know latina trans handicapped
chick and her travails in her in her
neighborhood I don't believe he wants to
see that I think they want to see
Saturday Night Live once he said alright
fever they want to see taxi driver they
want to see they don't want to they
don't really want to see that movie
that's so humble and so woke they want
to see a real movie movie but we are in
a place right now where in order to be
considered woke and maybe even hireable
at some of these places I think you have
to overpraise certain movies that
don't deserve it at all yeah so in a
second I want to ask you about that
because the critics it seems to me you
can almost it reeks off of some critics
when they don't like a movie and yet
they are banned by the prevailing
dominant Hollywood culture from saying
so like you can read it it's not even
between the lines it's basically seeping
off the page that's ripping down it and
I asked you about that in just a second
but first part of adulthood is having to
do things that you don't really want to
do like red-eye flights working late
watching us visiting in-laws and getting
life insurance but another part of
adulthood is learning to delegate what
you hate and while you can't delegate a
visit to the in-laws I know I know
you can definitely delegate life
insurance shopping policy genius is the
easy way to shop for life insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so if you need life
insurance but you just don't want to
deal with all the legwork head on over
to policy genius comm it's the easy way
to compare all the top insurers and find
the best value for you policy genius
delegate what you hate especially if you
hate getting life insurance be a
responsible adult go get life insurance
for yourself and your family if your
plots you don't want to leave your
family bearing you Anna poppers grabbing
them living in a hobo shelter especially
again if you hate getting life insurance
there's only one place to go policy
genius.com okay so one of the things
that you talked about in white is a
little bit about sort of how the critics
treat particular films and how if you
criticize a film in an honest way then
this is treated horribly whereas if
people go out of their way not to
critique a film but to talk about how
important a film is for example or how
bold the film is without actually
talking about the quality of the film
then this is the way to do it the most
recent example that I saw was the
critical treatment of us by Jordan Peele
where his first movie which I thought
was you know effective I didn't like it
bi critiqued it I thought that it had
serious racial flaws I thought that it
was actually racist in many ways because
the implication the film seemed to me to
be that if you're a black person who's
being dated by a white person and the
white person's family tries to take you
in they're actually trying to steal your
soul and make you not a person anymore
and trying to trying to destroy you as a
human I had serious problems that
premise but the film itself works and is
good so get out at least
was was well made the critics treatment
of us made me not want to see it because
the critical treatment of us was he's
such a great filmmaker Jordan Peele and
he's got so much potential and well he
didn't fulfill all of his potential here
he has some important things to say when
people say has some important things to
say
I immediately signal this is a bad film
why are why are so many critics hesitant
to actually just critique a film you
didn't want to see a horror movie about
income inequality you weren't interested
in seeing that movie
look look let's just be real here my
favorite show on television is Atlanta
I think Atlanta is absolutely a knockout
I think it's beautiful I think it's
brilliant and it's all about style it it
laces its ideology and its commentary
through a beautiful style that is
enveloping that is rich that is deeply
moving I think that when you get down to
again a kind of pure ideology overtaking
your film or your content you have a
real problem there and I do think again
you know look I got called out as being
racist when I said something about Black
Panther on my podcast thirty seconds on
my podcast as a man I said something
about black panther I said something
about I'm sick of Disney or Marvel you
know pushing this movie as a masterpiece
when of course we're pushing it because
it's a first because it's about
representation and apparently no one
heard me talk about how I loved the
opening images images of Wakanda and I
thought the blackness was the most
interesting thing about the movie it
just is another subpar Marvel movie and
that's that's what it is
and we just can't really pretend that
doesn't exist or you can if you want but
I do think the most it was the most
disturbing thing this year was the
critical reaction and evaluation of us
it was a a moment where you realize that
there's another world there's a secret
world where everyone is either so scared
of not calling out something on what it
is because I really don't know anybody
who liked us and I know a lot of people
who want to saw it and I think that it
we're we were in we're in this land
where the career
Consensus had to be that that if you
didn't love the movie and treat it with
the utmost seriousness which I'm not
sure it really deserves you were going
to be not only not look but you were
also going to be racist but this whole
thing of being racist for not liking
black themed content or not liking a
black movie has really spread out into
the whole society so every everything is
now racist everyone is now racist you're
racist I'm racist Katy Perry is racist
Bette Midler pizzetta tweet she's racist
I mean it we've gotten into a world
where real racism seems to be like you
know so diluted and watered down and
we're now talking about it in cultural
events and people reacting to movies or
a pair of shoes or whatever we've really
lost control of that narrative but
getting back to what you're saying about
us I think that was the moment this year
where you realize that there there is a
team and they're all playing kind of the
same game even in a critical I really
like I like Anthony Lane who writes for
The New Yorker and just knew us was
absolutely not his kind of movie and you
could see the path he took in order to
craft that review of us and very careful
doesn't coming right out and saying
anything about it stuff that I know
because I've been reading him for 30
years that he wouldn't like it maybe he
had to write it for The New Yorker maybe
the New Yorker that's what that you you
know that's the new command that you
better like with your like this so how
did you get into this industry in the
first place I mean how did you get into
writing you talk a lot in white about
your childhood and how you sort of
inculcated the film's of the of the
early 80s and late 70s how did you get
into doing what you do
well first off growing up out here
all of my peers and I want to be
filmmakers we all want to make movies it
is in some sections a company town much
like flint was a company town whatever
you grow up out here you have
connections to the movie industry you
want to make movies and you have to
understand that the TV industry wasn't
much of anything then it was you know so
we all want to make movies and what
happened was that I was also writing
books and so I wrote a novel called less
than zero during this time during my
adolescence
was published when I was 21 and that
became fairly successful and then it I
wanted to write other novels so the
whole idea of going to film school which
I decided not to do and went back east
to college was out the window and I
thought I could finish all the books
that I wanted to write in about the
space of 10 years it ultimately took
about 25 or 30 years to write those
books and it wasn't only it was really
only until about 10 years ago 12 years
ago that I got back into money to make
movies and the goal was never to be a
screenwriter I mean I grew up out here I
knew that the screenwriter thing was
just you know it wasn't it was a
lucrative business very lucrative
business in the 70s and into the 80s but
it wasn't filmmaking it was this kind of
very boring pedestrian job that you do
and I can't imagine being creatively
satisfying and it's really not
creatively the satisfying so it was
always about filmmaking and what
happened was that the kind of movies
that I want to make they stopped making
but I still want to make those movies so
finding them I was just on the phone
with a financier and my producer product
producing partner this morning and yeah
we can get a lot of the money from
Europe maybe some from here but the goal
was always altum Utley to make movies
and so when I came back out here after
being away writing my novels in New York
for about 25 years uh I got involved
producing writing a movie called The
Informers which was based on a book of
mine and it had it was it was at the end
of the expensive indie which meant an
expensive indie could cost 20 million
and no one would really blink an eye on
that in the early 2000s that was a
possibility unthinkable now and it was
it was let's say a very fraught
production a very long production very
big cast and it got ruined by the money
people producers a whole host of reasons
and it kind of soured my feeling about
making movies but you know I still I
still I mean I grew up in that era and
getting back to your your initial
question is that I grew up during the
1970s in this movie Mad era
we're great movies great American movies
were appearing in theaters almost if not
monthly than weekly and sir at certain
stages during that decade and that was
the prime time that was when I came of
age with my friends and so we all became
infected by the notion that you could
make movies as great as these movies
were and and and I have to say all of my
friends sticking into the into the movie
business and so you know you end up in
the movie business and you do some
screenwriting you do some fiction
writing now you've done nonfiction right
so which do you prefer look I still look
I've directed some some commercials I've
directed a web series I've directed a
few short films I like doing that it
once you start doing that you kind of
get bitten and you want to keep doing it
so that's but they're all enjoyable to
one degree or another let's let's make
make it clear I think writing non I
thought writing this book was far more
enjoyable than I ever thought it was
going to be because essentially when
you're writing a book is a literary
experience anyway it still is I mean
we're it's like writing fiction in a lot
of ways you know you want the words to
sound right you want the paragraphs to
be clear you want the narrative to
connect to a reader so I I find them all
pleasurable I I wouldn't do any of them
by if I'd if I found like maybe one more
pleasurable than the other I find them
all pleasurable so when you're writing
sort of what's your schedule and how
much do you go over and polish your
prose what's sort of your your your mode
how do you what's your style when you do
this I have to adhere to a schedule I
have to adhere to basically a 9:00 to
5:00 10:00 to 6:00 maybe 11:00 to 7:00
schedule where I do write everyday I
have my morning ritual and then I'm in
my office and then I take a break I
either go to the gym or I'll go to a
movie and then I'll come back and work
the rest of the afternoon up until about
7:00 or so and then you know how
cocktail or whatever but I like adhering
to that schedule and I pretty much have
always followed it if I'm getting toward
the end of something and I'm completing
it I might be working longer
because I'm just excited about the
prospect of finishing finishing the book
but um and I've always worked that way
I've always worked that way since I was
writing my novels in New York so in the
book you talked a little bit about David
Foster Wallace and I'm curious what
which are the writers that that in kind
of contemporaneous writers or older
writers that you actually like versus
some of the ones who you think our bure
because you're very critical obviously
of his of his writing well you know it's
it's I'm critical of again of an
overreaction to David Foster Wallace and
I'm and I'm reacting toward a rewritten
construct of the man I think the man was
a far more complicated much darker
person and kind of like a like an ass
very unlikable but he became kind of a
self-help guru for a lot of kids
especially after the suicide and he had
done this commencement speech that went
viral that was very hard to stomach it
was very aspirational and I don't know
David really believed in it but um
that's a good question the will look the
riders that meant a lot to me you really
only need to two or three you don't need
more than that everyone says oh all the
influences well I think at a certain
point obviously when I was very young it
was Hemingway and Hemingway uh really
opened the door maybe want to be a
writer
I love the writer Joan Didion her
nonfiction essays and her journalism
were hugely impactful very influential
and I write about her in the book and
white as well on one kind of level
Stephen King's novels were when I was in
adolescent I came of age right when he
started so I read Carrie when I was like
10 Salem's Lot when I was 12 the shining
when I was 13 I read that like five or
six times and and the shining actually
is an influence on a book of mine called
lunar Park which is kind of an homage to
Stephen King but then I also was uh
young enough well I was it was the right
period and minimalism has spread
throughout American fiction so people
like Raymond Carver to a degree Don
DeLillo this was happening in the early
80s and that was definitely a an
influence on less than zero but then of
course they're just writers that I love
I mean I love Tolstoy I love Faubert I
love Joyce I mean there's just a lot of
I just I love by the books I love novels
and so one of the terms that you use in
the book I used specifically with regard
to your partner
he's hi who's much younger than you are
and he talked about him as a member of
sort of the Millennial Generation moment
and you call Generation was what are the
characteristics of this generation what
the hell do you think happened all right
well what happened was first of all it
was nothing to be taken seriously it was
kind of a joke and I started to talk
about this on Twitter when I was
tweeting a lot more than I do now
and I just noticed that when we started
hanging out I'm sort of living together
that he was triggered by a lot of stuff
that just did not trigger me at all
and when we got into this terrible fight
our first fight was about the Tyler
Clemente Ravi Durham case where he put a
1 college kid pulled a prank on another
college kid causing the other kid to
commit suicide and I could not believe
that the how minor this prank was cause
a kid to kill himself it was outrageous
to me that there was something wrong
with kid and my partner said no I
completely understand that
that is a violation that should never
have happened this is a private moment
for the other kid who committed suicide
voilá and I just couldn't believe that I
was listening to this and then there
were a lot of other things there was a
kind of passive-aggressive positivity
that I knew was kind of not real there
was this unwavering belief belief in all
things inclusive all things diverse a
kind of utopian attitude that I just
seemed so unreal to me that there's that
this was just some kind of fantasy life
and there was also this kind of
deep-rooted shame about everything about
I think a lot of it connected to
exhibiting yourself on social media and
beans being like everyone is kritis
relentlessly so he was kind of crippled
by all of these things not to the point
that he couldn't get out of bed or
anything but it was a vast difference
between his generation and my generation
his was kind of a touchy-feely
millennial generation and I of course
came out of Gen X which is very cool and
ironic and I'm not saying cool and I'm
you know good with cold let's say cold
and aloof and ironic and Niall istic and
I do think that the millennial
generation is for all their annoyances
all the things that I find annoying
about them is a reaction against that is
a reaction against Gen X thinking and
the Gen X mindset and I think the
reaction that Millennials have to this
section in white it has been hysteric
I mean absolute asterick the Millennial
reviewers have one one transgender
millennial reviewer who got so upset
with this book that she wrote I think a
three thousand four thousand page review
talking about how old I am how
irrelevant I am how white I am how
unwell I am and she kept repeating this
over and over and over in the most air
achill language possible for 4,000 words
so that seems to me to be exhibit a of
what I wasn't talking about when
Millennials have this overreaction to
something and so but I guess she didn't
read the final section of that
particular section where I talk about
why I'm sympathetic to them as well so
why are you sympathetic to it - because
you know look they've been through a lot
to a degree they've been through two
wars they've been through their living
with a president they can't stand the
their economic reality is far different
than mine was in terms of their
fulfilling their hopes their aspirations
and their dreams it was much easier for
my generation to do that because of an
economic safety collision and also
because of the horrible damaging effects
of social media which I know I'm
sounding like the old guy on the porch
but but I am the old guy on the force
and I always have
I was the old guy on the porch when I
was a teenager so it really not a lot
has changed so um I don't that's why I'm
sympathetic to my partner who well you
know a college graduate going out for
jobs and just being the only things that
were open were unpaid in internships and
it was kind of like are you effing
kidding me this is what this is where
your generation is so I'm sympathetic as
much as I have been critical I and I and
look I've lived with one for 10 years so
it's not as if I'm not getting something
out of it you talk a lot into about
social media in white and I as a devotee
of social media particularly Twitter I
found that in the last six months to a
year alone I've realized that if I don't
disconnect from this thing it will kill
me yeah I was good friends with with
Andrew Breitbart with whom I worked
closely and Andrew was connected at the
hip to social media I am firmly
convinced that it was responsible for
much of his high blood pressure and some
of the in a lot of the stress in his
life yes social media it's fascinating
is you talk in the book about how you
just tweeting things drives people up a
wall and how you weren't really prepared
for that maybe we can talk a little bit
about sort of the impact of Twitter and
what Twitter was fun see this is what
everyone forgets Twitter when I started
out was fun and it was a place to make
outrageous statements that didn't define
your humanity there were just jokes and
everything was in kind of quotation
marks it was kind of performative and
you said something kind of outrageous
everyone kind of gasped and then moved
on five seconds later it was I never saw
Twitter to be built as a place for me to
virtue signal and talk about how
wonderful I am and to attack other
people for their opinions and for what
they what their beliefs are or to take
them to task for being you know this
whole notion that we should all be happy
about speech lock down in a way and that
the language police are a good thing
because it means that well no one can
talk in racist terms and sexist terms
and homophobic terms I don't believe
that
the thing that's going on I believe is
this vast Puritanism that's going on
right now and that's keeping everyone a
child forever coddling them from
offensive opinions from viewpoints that
are different from yours and I can die I
noticed the connection between this
between what Twitter once was and what
Twitter warped into and as naughty and
disturbing for some Twitter was in the
its first days people had a good time
people were not stressed out and then
people started to lose jobs because of
tweets then people started to lose
things because of tweets and then there
was this flowering of social justice
warriors and a flowering of virtue
signaling and calling out people to get
their accounts canceled because they
said this thing or that thing and it
really has it has warped into something
that was really fun into really a toxic
nightmare I keep it because my newsfeed
is on it and it's very easy it is very
user friendly in terms of like what I
want on it but and I do I have really
been careful at getting rid of people in
terms of okay I don't want that toxicity
in my life I don't want this I mean I
like people who are critical who have
opinions but then when it gets into you
know where I you know level 100 of
negativity and toxicity then I can't I
can't bear it but I have gotten into
trouble for for tweets of mine and it
just that was kind of like the beginning
of when I said on trouble for a tweet
Twitter is real Twitter is this thing
that you take so seriously
it was um kind of the beginning of the
end for me and I I rarely use that I use
it as a kind of promotional tool though
actually Facebook works better than and
then Twitter does for me and every now
and then on an opinion on a movie or
something but I not I'm not the person
I'm not I don't have the Twitter persona
that I once had and I know that people
are disappointed by that but it's just
it's just to another rotten wrecks your
life I mean it's active roster life
there's so many people also out there
who are using those old tweets from the
playful days as sort of the sort of
Damocles hanging over you where if you
don't you do not just obey whatever is
the dick taught of the day and the dick
taught changes daily like we don't know
what the rules are into the rules change
on a routine basis and so they'll hold
some joke tweet that he had from 2009
over you and then if you say the wrong
thing then they retweeted at you and
suddenly it's a pile on and I'm not
talking about me personal I'm talk about
folks like James Gunn right James Gunn
was using Twitter in exactly this way
back in 2009 2010 and then he ran afoul
of some folks politically and suddenly
he was seeing all of these tweets
resurfaced and the media were treating
it as though it was actual news that he
had made these gross strokes back in
2009 2010 when he was doing shock comedy
and we're seen with Kevin Hart too I
mean just this this and it's not just
Twitter anymore it's this whole thing
where we are going to apply whatever is
the modern sensibility to something that
someone said not 80 years ago but
something that someone said ten years
ago and was considered perfectly
mainstream in order to destroy their
life and in order to cudgel them into
line over here really is it's
devastating I don't know how you can
have a culture a common culture one this
is the the way that things go well you
can't but I also have learned that I
ultimately have learned that I don't
really care that much
I have never deleted any of my tweets
and I am I'm someone who accidentally
tweeted for drugs when I thought I was
texting one night where I was really
wasted and my partner was out and he
called me and said I want to be home
about an hour and then I put the phone
down
oh yeah maybe and so I was texting and I
said hey come over bring over some drugs
or sin sin and then I went to bed and
the next day I woke up and there was
like a thousand and I had actually
tweeted that out my 600,000 followers in
the middle of the night so and that's
still up there
I have never deleted that tweet either
so I'm I you know I find it toxic now I
it really kind of makes me nervous in a
way but I have not deleted any tweets
and I am I can't get I can't fall into
the fear of like people finding tweets
of mine from 2010-2011 and how bad could
they be after that one
your drugs on Twitter what what I make a
I don't know so I mean how weird is it
for you to end up in a place where
you're welcomed on Fox News you come on
shows like this one you you're more
welcomed I would say on the political
right by a lot of folks then you have
been on the political left now you're
obviously not politically conservative
in like the traditional sense I don't
think so how how did this happen I don't
know how that this happened Ben I again
I think as someone who saw himself as
really not caring about politics at all
really not being much more focused on
writing novels and on art and on film
there's just something about this moment
that has dragged everybody into it and
so I see myself as not a conservative
not a liberal I'm certainly not a
Republican I'm certainly not a Democrat
I'm not on the right I'm not on the Left
I'm an observer and there are things
going on in the culture right now that
kind of drive me to distraction and I'm
annoyed by and I talk about this on my
podcast and it mostly is about this
Puritanism that I see washing through
the public and I don't know where that's
going to go with an over reactive
hysteric populace that is overreacting
to everything and including I believe
Trump and so but that hit the nerve when
I talk about it in other aspects of the
culture people will go oh yeah maybe
whatever but when you talk about this in
terms of Trump people go nuts and they
assume because you're criticizing the
mainstream media and you're criticizing
people losing their over Trump that
you are in fact a trump supporter and
that you support Trump when that's not
true
but again I feel the message is clear
and I am happy to talk to anybody I also
don't live in a bubble and this is
something that I write about in white I
have plenty of friends who like Trump
and I have plenty of friends who don't
as I said I live with a millennial
communist so I hear 24/7 everything
horrible about Trump I have friends and
acquaintances who really liked
so I have always lived in hearing both
sides and I understand what my friends
who like from like prom and I understand
my friends who don't like drum
don't like drum but just because I have
not taken a side doesn't mean that I'm
on this side for Trump and I think that
it's been very interesting how open in a
way one side of the aisle has been in
terms of having me on and talk about
this book and how closed one side has
been as well look I've done I've been
profiled with the New York Times Los
Angeles Times in Washington Post but I
also was profiled by Breitbart and I
think that's totally acceptable and
that's totally fine and if some person
is gonna pull their hair out and have
you know rive and horror that I'm doing
this well you know you need to relax a
little bit I know my partner didn't like
the notion that I would talk to
Breitbart and certainly didn't like the
idea that I was went on Fox and talked
to Tucker Carlson and was having a big
problem with that but then you know
Bernie went on Fox and it all kind of
became okay for him in a way so it's
like okay yeah I think you can do more
Fox shows he said I think he should go
to you Steve Hilton and whoever whoever
else once you want and and I think that
divided I don't like that divide that
notion that we all can't be talking I'm
sure there are things you and I do not
agree on I'm sure there are things that
we might strongly disagree on but that
doesn't mean that I can't have a
conversation with you I was highly
highly disturbed by what happened to you
with Mark Duplass who is someone I've
had on my podcast and that whole I mean
not to you know bring it all up back out
but I just couldn't believe that there
was this group thing that sucked him in
made him rearrange his feelings about
you and then post them was kind of a
real moment I can still remember and I'm
still talking about I think it's the
same thing that happened when David
Lynch gave an interview in 2018 said he
thinks well who knows maybe Donald Trump
will be the greatest president in
history and then there was so much
outrage that he had to and who knows who
talked to him had to print out on
Facebook an apology that he said this
I'm surprised that Lynch did that I mean
it would
think he's too old and doesn't really
give it about that but that's where we
are and I and I hate that and I and I
like the idea that people from different
sides of the aisle and sit in a room
like this
and just talk about stuff and it doesn't
necessarily have to be about the thing
the you know DT you know it can be about
a lot of other stuff but it is true the
the left is much much more prone to not
dealing with me with this book been the
right has been but I don't but I don't
like that and so III really I've always
felt that way I talk to everybody
well I'm just a second I'm gonna ask you
the final question which is I want you
to rank maybe your top five movies of
all time your five favorite movies but
if you want to hear Bret Easton Ellis's
answer then you actually have to be a
daily wire subscriber to subscribe head
on over to daily wire comm click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation over there Bret Easton
Ellis thank you so much for stopping by
really great to see you could see them I
think thank you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jesuit Alvaro
title graphics by Cynthia angular the
Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Applause]